So, I'm also really excited as well.
(Sam) Now basically...so basically...
So, basically...
(Dwayne Johnson) Alright, let's try; and so, this happens to people all the time
(Wren) Twenty seven visual effects shots in this piece.
Well...
(Carmichael) Today's Tuesday.
(Wren) Yeah...
(Carmichael) This should be done by Friday.
You have three days to do 27 shots.
(Wren) No, this isn't, this isn't going to be done by Friday
(Sam) I'm in New York City today, because I'm shooting a promotional
video with Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
This is a really intense experience for myself, because he is literally
the biggest celebrity right now.
And I have to admit, I'm usually not starstruck, but I'm...
I'm pretty nervous about meeting him because he's such an intense guy.
I have been selected to go and shoot our promotional video for Lifeline with him.
We only have twenty minutes with him
We have all night to prepare and set up our set for the shoot.
We're going to see how all of this goes.
Wish me luck.
About two in the morning now.
We have taken our large hotel suite here,
and we converted it into a small set.
Complete with lights and a white backdrop
because tomorrow morning we have twenty minutes to shoot and we have to be 100% ready.
So, we just spent all night pre-lighting everything.
This hotel room is so fancy and crazy.
There's even, like, a secret door here.
That opens up to a whole other room.
Easily the most expensive looking room I've ever stayed in in my entire life.
(Wren) That means I have to average nine shots per day.
Excluding whatever shots I'm able to get done today.
Most of the effects are...
compositing a green screen element onto a wall,
and that's actually pretty simple, because
it's a shadow. You're just going to turn that plate into
black and white.
I'm able to- I'm able to kick through these shadow effects pretty quickly.
We have to have all the effects done by tomorrow, and
there's still a lot of effects left to do.
So Gabe...
I am- I am recruiting you to do some very tedious stuff.
It takes a lot of time.
Because if you can take that off my plate, I think I might be able to finish all the rest of the effects.
That's why I'm screen capturing, Carmichael...
(Carmichael) You're screen-capturing this shot, this monitor.
(Wren) Yeah.
(Carmichael) But you're describing what's happening on this monitor.
(Wren) But...
So, Brett's getting dragged across the floor,
and we have to basically paint out all of
Jake, but not of the backpack.
(Gabe) Yeah.
(Wren) So we got the footage here,
I turn it off; we have an exact replica of the background.
Do a pass where you literally put a mask
straight up through and over.
Set that to subtract...
Now that we basically cut out Jake for the entirety of the shot, we need
we need to add back in Brett.
So that's how this is a two stage process here.
(Sam) It's a fact that we're out of water.
It's 12:47, and we are minutes away from actually shooting this thing,
And I'm here with all sorts of people.
We're with Dennis, our DP, Scott, from Seven7Box, with Kurt, who's generally just a cool guy
and helped us figure out this entire lighting setup.
and [unintelligible], but he's not here right now.
Everyone's finally starting to arrive, meaning
it's about to get very, very real.
(greetings around)
(Dwayne Johnson) I see, okay, so, I see, so
[unintelligible] copy all the way through,
two times, just to get an idea of what we're doing.
(Sam) Exactly
(Dwayne Johnson) Yeah, so what really just happens
to be in that space, in terms of promotion.
(Sam) Also, like contemplative, like
like you don't know, you don't quite know how this works.
They don't know that time travel is involved at all.
So to them, it's just a fluke.
(Wren) Gabe's actually pretty good at After Effects, so
I've got no worries.
Should I be worried?
This video has 29 visual effects shots.
The vast majority of them aren't too complicated, and I
can go through fairly quickly.
I've already kicked out, I think, 6 shots today.
Rotoscoping is just one of those things that takes a lot of time.
But the time that it would take for me to do the backpack shot, just roto-ing out the backpack
and getting that shot done, I could have done 2 or 3 shadow shots.
So just logistically speaking, with our schedule, it makes more sense to pass that off to someone else.
(Gabe) Wren makes it look so easy...
(Wren) Gabe's really good at animation and whatnot, After Effects...
Considering this is the first time he's used the roto brush,
It's hard for me to say how long it'll take him to do
It'd probably take me...
I'm not even remotely worried that Gabe isn't going to get this done.
We're wasting time here. I could be doing some green-screening,
(Carmichael) That's not my time that's being wasted!
(Wren) It's my time! That's my point!
(Carmichael) Yeah, who's responsible for that?
(Wren) That...but...you brought me in here.
Gabe finished those two shots. They're excellent.
Good job Gabe.
(Carmichael) Is he going to do more?
(Wren) No.
(Carmichael) If he did those so quickly,
like, give him more work!
(Wren) Not the end just yet, got another couple hours.
I have, since we last talked,
finishing up this one right now, so that's three more.
I'm almost done with this shot, so...
I actually think I might be able to get all of these done by tomorrow.
Wait, so, this is
Thursday evening, right now.
And this is going up in tomorrow's vlog?
(Carmichael) Yeah!
(Wren) Hey, look at you guys!
So we have shots we have to film, and there's a drone shot I need to get.
(Carmichael) And you're going to do all of that tomorrow.
Yeah, and there's like a whole bunch of work here.
Ooh, Gabe can help me with that stuff.
(Gabe) What stuff?
(Wren) I'll tell you tomorrow.
(Gabe) I'm not going to be here tomorrow.
Who is this master?
Jonathon...DeBoz...
This kid is a comedic genius.
Gold. It's gold!
Go watch that video. Johnyboz is great.
I've pretty much stop stuck with it ever since
you know
working-out every day
the only down side is that
I can't wear shirts with sleeves anymore my muscles are to big